he comes into the subway he asks for
food and water and this is how he gets
treated maybe you like he was doing one
of those videos right maybe he had a
thousand bucks in his pocket
did they check him out and see if he had
a thousand bucks
[Music]
all right so this is in the news right
now because we are the news there's a
dude
who has just died after being put in a
choke hold by another Rider on a New
York City I saw this video I heard about
this you saw the video saw the video
yeah the guy holds him a choke hold for
like 15 minutes oh my god oh is it the
guy that it's like a long time that that
um they said that he was being like
belligerent and [__] yeah he wasn't
being well different this is where I
mean it's still under investigation you
follow U.S crime on Instagram it's been
popping up and then I just saw this kid
like like in a Michael Jackson suit and
then they're like they they murdered
this dude this guy said that he was
being like
um loud or asking like yelling at people
so he had to like hold him down but he
was choking them yeah and I was like I
didn't watch the video so I don't know
what went down but that's like the
narrative that was like a marine right
his name is Jordan Neely
um I don't know anything about a marine
but he definitely was a well-known
Michael Jackson no the Marines the yeah
the chocolate oh okay so the one guy's
the uh like a Michael Jackson street
performer he like performs in the subway
car he's like 30 years old or something
so that's the one guy and then the other
guy's like a real tough guy the other
guy's like a former Marine age 24 yeah
why why did he want to choke out of
Michael Jackson impersonator that makes
because he came he came onto the subway
car saying I want food and water I'm not
taking No Finance I'm Gonna Hurt
Somebody I don't care if I go to jail
I'll do a life sentence what that's what
he was saying uh the Michael Jackson
person who said that yeah he also has
had 40 prior arrests that's a weird
Michael Jackson but did he do it like I
don't know if that's an exact quote from
Michael yeah that's I don't I don't
think maybe those are lyrics in the high
voice oh that's from I can't stop loving
you oh [__] now he was talking to the to
the man in the mirror dude he wasn't
talking about it yeah he he was like
going off basically and I'm not gonna
take no man in the mirror is probably my
favorite Michael Jackson song yeah
[Music]
he said he was going to hurt people
basically on the on the train so dude
just try to restrain him they said that
the dude I don't know in the video was
the guy resisting in the video now what
happened in the video video I saw it was
this dude this white guy with curly hair
choking out yeah uh the Michael Jackson
impersonator it started with the choke
out already that's where I saw that
video from oh and there was like two
other guys holding down his legs so
there was three guys holding him down
and then one guy was choking him out but
in the in the caption I don't know how
true this is it was saying he was
holding him in the choke hold for 15
minutes and I was like well that sounds
they said it was a long time but also in
the in the report they said the dude was
struggling almost the entire time too
like he was like he was trying to get he
wasn't like okay fine like he was like
trying to get out the whole time so they
didn't that's why they didn't stop
holding them down the point of the video
that I saw and it was once again it was
like 10-15 seconds he was like choked he
looked like he was unconscious but damn
that might have been towards tail end of
the video because on Instagram people
trying to get those views is this is
this sparking like another George Floyd
kind of thing yeah it's like white and
black and and and racism and all that or
is it like the point of view that I
heard is that no they're the protests
are saying no one should be able to take
a life that way but he tried to protect
people so there's that side oh yeah it's
definitely conflicting yeah it's
conflicting like crazy yeah I mean no
one should be able to drive into
neighborhoods and just start shooting
each other and have stray bullets hating
people either I guess because they were
saying he was having a mental health
crisis he hadn't yet like attacked
anyone I don't believe he hadn't but he
made a threat yeah he was making verbal
threats okay I don't know and again this
guy's had so they're proposing every
subway car should have a licensed
psychiatrist like in every single subway
car to prevent them I think my question
would be yeah if he made the threats
right like because we hear homeless
people say crazy [__] all the time most
people just most people just ignore them
but did the marine guy hear the threat
jump up and like just start choking them
immediately no no no or did they tell
them calm down like did they try to
de-escalate I think because I didn't
yeah I didn't see the videos I don't
know I feel like people in New York are
also used to a different level yeah I
don't know I would say crazy but just
like wild [__] that would happen so I
feel like most of the Times Like New
Yorkers are just like yeah whatever so
the fact that like he was acting in a
way that caused such a big reaction for
multiple people is also notable right
you should take the subway in LA and
you're just used to that [__] people
coming in and screaming and all kinds of
yeah you're used to a homeless man just
[__] peeing on the floor and
everyone's just like moving away like
dude it's sad it's definitely said that
he died like I'm sure that's not what
the that Marine guy probably didn't want
to kill him like that but he had to hold
him right if my mom was on that train
I'd be like [__] take the dude out
yeah for sure no exactly I hate to say
that
it's nice when we're judging something
from afar but when you're actually there
under Potential Threat like you don't I
don't I don't care put myself there and
if someone's been threatening over and
over like I don't care if I go to jail
someone better give me food or water
whatever it's like oh [__] and
especially nowadays with all like the
the shootings that you see and all the
wild stuff that's been happening and the
media like heightening it like I think
most people are just on edge anyway so I
saw this bully cholo like in um the LA
rail system there's a video of him just
like pumpkin people and then like being
hella aggressive he hasn't [__]
anybody up yet but he's in their faces
like and it looked like right there when
he was about to punch someone and then
this guy comes up grabs him in a choke
hold puts them to sleep yeah and this
was and I'm thinking like if it was like
that bad where this guy's like an inch
away in front of people's faces and like
it looks like something's gonna erupt
into violence then to me that makes
sense why why you would do it but if
he's just like yelling at people in the
Train by himself I mean he was Far Away
acting erratically he said he was Fed Up
and hungry he said I'm tired of having
nothing I don't care if I die I don't
care if I go to jail I don't have any
food I'm done so I think our
conversation that's always kind of or
that's also being brought up is just
kind of the the rise in like
homelessness and like the not being able
to take care of the people the right way
so you're putting people into a corner
as well where they don't have anything
so when you have your back against the
wall like you got nothing to lose it's
going to spark more things like this but
what what I would ask is
do you know again I don't know how to
put people in [__] chokeholds and
stuff like that can you
tell when you're going to either
strangle somebody or put them to sleep
can you control putting somebody to
sleep you can feel them go limp
like you can feel people like when they
pass up there's the difference between
that passing out and dying well here's
the thing is like when they pass out in
like 10 to 15 seconds once blood rushes
back to their head they'll probably wake
up again so then you put them to sleep
in and then you wait let them wake up
and no I'm just kidding you don't do
that holy crap I was like what though no
no you don't do that that's probably the
worst way to do it it's a gangster yeah
I think I think at that time that's when
it's really important to understand how
to like restrain somebody right like to
be able because there's a way you could
physically hold somebody down without
cutting off there without having to like
slam somebody on their head or make them
unconscious there's a way to restrain
that's my favorite way though honestly
yeah and Bart's always suplexing people
is it is it easier to do it with
multiples versus one yeah definitely so
so this is it I think you're technically
a homicide as a death by compression of
neck AKA Chokehold so it's like Jesus
like what it would it but that's the
problem is like this guy and
the Marine kid he knows enough to be
dangerous but like he like he knows
enough to kill somebody which is is that
some Con Air [__] that's Connor [__]
right that's like hey you're technically
trained killer at the same time as he's
saving the lives of the subway if
they're going crazy who knows exactly
yeah I think that's the hard part for me
because like did the marine guy walk all
the way across from the other side of
the train to restrain this dude did he
overreact
um because he's not from New York and
he's just not or is it was a guy like
this close and then he goes oh [__] this
guy's about to [__] everybody up for
real you know like did he have to kill
him is the question right exactly
because like you just don't know or is
he if he's struggling around like what
Ryan's saying the whole time he might
not even know he's just like oh [__]
yeah and then if he's holding on for
long enough
it's like oh [__] I didn't even know I
killed him because for me it's like
what got him to that point but if he's
already there then that is like yeah to
me if you're already in this position
then yeah you might kill someone you
might not right but the point of getting
there is where I'm not sure if it's
Justified or not the one of the top
comments I saw that like had a bunch of
likes was like someone said uh
the a guy who shows up on a train asking
for food and water and this is how you
respond to it but I'm like that's not
really you're gonna cherry pick that
part yeah not put in the part where he
said I'm gonna kill someone or like I
want to hurt somebody like Yeah and I
don't care if I go to jail like that
part's the most important my question to
that guy would be like if he's asking
for food and water let him go to Costco
why you go to Subway there's literally
no food or water anyway he went to the
wrong Subway go to yeah supposed to go
to Subway with a sign in the green and
the yellow not an actual Subway dude I
went to Las Vegas I didn't caught zero
trout but honestly I'd rather no [__]
[__] I'd rather not even go to
that Subway though yeah
but yeah the fact he died as a result of
a good citizen trying to neutralize a
threat is highly unfortunate I would
personally in my life would love if
someone was around that could help like
what this guy did I don't want somebody
killing everybody around like someone
with [__] webs and [__] but on the
flip side though like isn't that the
right way to act in society yeah
definitely on the flip side is like
did you have to choke them out the whole
time right if you got three guys holding
somebody down because that the video I
saw was three guys or if he's not if
he's unarmed right it looked like yeah
he they're on top of him he has his back
we'll hold them in an armor just [__]
hold them like this keep your head
inside three other guys or two other
guys will hold his legs down just wait
wait till the next one he was like
[__] being belligerent the whole time
but dude he wasn't no place to move
right what if he Moon walks out of it
the only thing dude remember the Lost
remember the Las Vegas Michael Jackson
impersonator who took down that one
belligerent [__] imagine this
marine and that Jiu Jitsu Michael
Jackson [__]
like a John Cena versus the Michael
Jackson where's the piggyback off of
what what Ryan's saying like that
commenter he's like he comes into the
subway he asks for food and water and
this is how he gets treated maybe like
he was doing one of those videos right
maybe he had a thousand bucks in his box
did they check him did they check him
and see if he had a thousand bucks
then you know they're like so here's
some food and water he's like here I
wanted to give you a thousand dollars
I'm like oh no no I can't take it and
he's like no no no you you helped me I
want to give you a thousand dollars he
was trying to do a social experiment and
then when he gets choked down his
friends like from bail maybe that's why
he'll squirm it the whole time I got a
thousand bucks yeah he's trying to reach
the thousand bucks it's fine no
oh no you should always check to just
say yes and then you'll get maybe get a
thousand bucks that would be the worst
alcohol Undercover Boss who just wanted
to be they just wanted to make a viral
Tick Tock video yeah you you go on that
Subway every day you've seen this guy
all the time you know he's had 40 prior
arrests you're like maybe he's got a
thousand bucks today you see the road
mic on his [__] dirt oh what um oh
God that's a road mic this is a
production I just hope it doesn't make
people think twice about helping like it
already is yeah you know what I mean
like people like you'll get either this
or you'll get why didn't anyone do
anything yeah like you just get one yeah
that's true
we often make a vote with the imperfect
information there's more information but
I'm not even gonna give it where are you
guys voting right now for the potential
suspect of the marine guy that's hard if
I hear a threat being made and if
something I neutralize the threat I'm
always going to be on the neutralizer
yeah because I think even if he killed
him neutralizes a hell of a word to you
it's there my friend because he didn't
just neutralize the guy oh no he [__]
equalized him dude equalizer three dude
yeah
it's hard because I'm not in that train
but if I was saying if I was in the
train I saw a a guy making a threat to
the train
I'm not gonna assume
I'm not going to assume that this person
has mental problems and we need to be
delicate and lovely I'm just gonna think
this might this guy might have a gun and
if someone chokes him out I'm like thank
you and then after I feel bad because
I'm like oh he had mental health
problems but that's the issue right
because think about how all the people
go oh all he wanted to do to rob you
but then it's like yeah it's true like
like after the fact right but when
someone breaks into your home or when
someone poses a threat you can't assume
intent you
times out if you break into this home
are you going to rape me or are you just
gonna come in and steal my kitchen
knives and then go home because you need
to [__] cut turkey or whatever right
it's like you don't know the intent of
the person that is posing this threat so
then and you're under duress in that
moment exactly so if someone says
they're gonna kill you and then they
just met oh it's a figure of speech but
I just said it aggressively I wasn't
really gonna do it but then if they get
eliminated for making a threat then to
me I'm like you played with fire my
whole thing is if they break into my
house how do I know they're not trying
to give me a thousand dollars
laughs
[Music]